vamos a hacer un experimento clásico
vamos a observar esta luz a través de
esta regla transparente desde la parte
de enmedio y desde la parte de arriba y
como mi cámara tiene una lente grande
podemos ver ambas al mismo tiempo esta
es la imagen de la parte de enmedio de
la regla y esta es la imagen de la parte
de arriba de la regla si disminuimos la
exposición podemos ver que el tubo de
luz de la parte de arriba se ve con
colores y al ver la imagen de enmedio no
se ve con colores la pregunta es por qué
ocurre esto aquí tenemos una mejor
imagen porque al ver la luz desde la
parte de arriba la vemos con colores y
cuando la vemos desde la parte de
enmedio no se ven colores para responder
a esto vamos a ver de perfil lo que
sucede vamos a verlo de este lado aquí
está la vista de perfil aquí está la
regla aquí es donde estaba la cámara y
por eso dibujé un ojo aquí y aquí está
la fuente de luz si dibujamos un par de
rayos de luz uno que va hacia la parte
de en medio de la regla y el otro que va
hacia él
de arriba de la regla porque no vemos
colores aquí porque si vemos colores acá
arriba cuál es la diferencia entre estos
dos vamos a acercarnos para observar lo
que ocurre ahora podemos ver la
diferencia y la diferencia está en que
en la parte de enmedio a ambos lados de
la regla son paralelos pero en la parte
de arriba los dos lados no son paralelos
entre sí así que por alguna razón cuando
la luz pasa por la parte de los lados
paralelos no se ven colores pero sí se
ven colores cuando la luz blanca pasa
por la parte que no tiene los lados
paralelos queremos averiguar por qué
ocurre esto veamos lo que sucede cuando
la luz pasa por la parte de arriba de la
regla que tiene lados no paralelos que
hemos dibujado aquí y luego veremos lo
que ocurre cuando la luz pasa por el
medio que tiene los lados paralelos
cuando tenemos un medio que no tiene
lados paralelos en general llamamos
prismas a tales medios pero la mayor
parte de las veces que hablamos de
prismas nos referimos a prismas
triangulares
si vemos un prisma triangular
tridimensional tendrá más o menos esta
forma dos bases o caras con forma
triangular por eso se llama prisma
triangular y una de las caras la vemos
aquí es el mismo prisma pero visto de
frente las dos bases triangulares están
unidas por estas tres caras laterales
rectangulares aquí está una cara
rectangular por aquí está la otra cara
rectangular y por abajo está la otra
cara rectangular
este es un prisma triangular
y el ángulo formado por estas dos caras
rectangulares se le conoce como ángulo
del prisma
y esta parte de arriba también es un
prisma triangular si se fijan es un
triángulo un triángulo rectángulo es un
prisma triangular y este es un ángulo
muy bien veamos qué es lo que sucede
cuando pasa un rayo de luz a través de
un prisma triangular como este
imaginemos que un rayo de luz llega
desde la izquierda vamos a acercar la
imagen para dibujar el rayo imaginemos
que tenemos un rayo de luz que llega
desde la izquierda lo que va a ocurrir
aquí es que este rayo se va a desviar
porque cambia de medio y para comprender
cómo se desvía el rayo por lo general
dibujamos una recta normal aquí
dibujamos una recta perpendicular a esta
que es la recta normal y ahora este rayo
va a pasar del vacío a otro medio que
puede ser vidrio o quizá plástico lo que
sea como resultado el rayo va a ir más
despacio porque la luz tiene su máxima
velocidad en el vacío y conforme la luz
va más despacio se va a desviar hacia la
normal
es algo que hemos visto en vídeos sobre
refracción por lo que si quieren saber
más del por qué ocurre esto los invito a
que pause en este vídeo y vayan a ver
los vídeos sobre refracción y luego
regresen a ver este así que este rayo se
va a desviar y va de esta forma pero al
ir más despacio se desvía hacia la recta
normal así ahora nuevamente llega a esta
interfase y de nuevo se va a desviar voy
a dibujar otra recta normal de esta
forma ahora va a pasar de este medio al
vacío lo que significa que va a aumentar
su velocidad y se va a desviar lejos de
la normal así que este rayo que venía
así ahora se va a desviar lejos de la
normal
de esta forma aquí lo tenemos esto es lo
que hace la luz cuando pasa a través de
este prisma podemos ver que la luz se ha
desviado dos veces en la misma dirección
en ambos casos se dobló hacia abajo y
como resultado el rayo emergente se
desvía de su ruta inicial lo ven
el rayo tenía esta dirección pero al
pasar por el prisma este rayo ya no
tiene esa dirección
ahora se desvió con un ángulo como éste
y ahora se mueve en esta dirección esto
es lo que hacen los prismas los prismas
desvían los rayos de luz que pasan a
través de ellos y quizás se pregunten
qué tiene que ver esto con lo que vimos
al principio bueno recuerden que este es
un solo color de luz pero si tenemos un
rayo de luz blanca como la que vemos
aquí la luz blanca está formada por los
siete colores del arco iris y hemos
visto en vídeos anteriores que cuando la
luz blanca pasa de un medio a otro los
diferentes colores se desvían de forma
distinta el color rojo es el que se
desvía menos y el color azul el que se
desvía más como resultado de que los
colores se desvían diferente es que
podemos ver estos colores por separado
vamos a verlo
así es como luce esta imagen está un
poco exagerada pero pueden ver que aquí
está la luz blanca
estos dos rayos están desviados hacia
abajo como lo vimos aquí
pero como la luz roja se desvía menos
podemos ver que se dobló poco y como la
luz azul es la que más se desvía el
resultado es que se han separado los
colores y es por eso que vemos colores
en la parte de arriba bueno pasará lo
mismo aquí abajo ahora veamos lo que
sucede cuando un rayo de luz pasa por
aquí vamos a ignorar esta versión y
consideremos un solo color ya hemos
visto lo que ocurre aquí cuando un rayo
de luz incide en un medio con lados
paralelos
el rayo emergente será paralelo al rayo
incidente es decir que el rayo emergente
va a tener la misma dirección que el
rayo incidente esto ocurre porque aquí
la luz se desvía hacia la recta normal y
luego se desvía lejos de la normal y
como ambos lados son paralelos
ambas desviaciones se cancelan por lo
que el resultado es que el rayo
emergente es paralelo al rayo incidente
esta es la gran diferencia entre esto y
esto aquí debido a que ambos lados están
en ángulo el rayo emergente no va
ser paralelo al rayo incidente y si
ahora reemplazamos esto con luz blanca
veremos dispersión vamos a reemplazarlo
con la luz blanca de nuevo igual a lo
que vimos aquí la luz roja se desvía
menos y la luz azul es la que más se
desvía pero como los rayos emergentes
tienen que ser paralelos al rayo
incidente vean que el rojo y el azul
emergen paralelos entre sí esta es una
gran diferencia aquí el rojo y el azul
no son paralelos entre sí pero aquí sí
son paralelos entre sí y debido a que
los colores son paralelos al observarlos
no podemos ver coloración y solo vemos
blanco pero por qué sucede esto esto
tiene sentido si recordamos un detalle
importante que en la realidad no tenemos
solo un rayo de luz sino que siempre
tenemos varios rayos de luz dibujemos un
rayo más de luz para ver qué es lo que
sucede si dibujamos otro rayo de luz en
la parte de abajo hay un par de formas
en las que podemos convencernos de que
no veremos colores aquí una forma es que
como tenemos dos rayos
luz aquí si estos dos rayos estuvieran
más cerca el uno del otro pueden ver que
el rojo y el azul se trasladarían entre
sí de forma similar si dibujamos otro
rayo de luz blanca
quizá el color amarillo sería el que se
traslapa con el azul aquí y si
dibujáramos otro entonces quizá el color
verde es el que se traslade aquí en
resumen lo que sucede aquí es que si
consideramos muchos rayos de luz que
llegan entre estos y si consideramos
todos los colores
debido a que estos rayos emergen
paralelos entre sí siempre se traslapan
entre sí todos los colores se mezclan
por lo que vemos luz blanca pero en este
otro prisma no sucede lo mismo
consideremos otro rayo de luz acá la
diferencia principal es que los colores
no son paralelos entre sí por lo que no
se van atrás la par pueden ver que
aunque se trasladen un poco aquí al
final se van a separar y es por eso que
el rojo y el azul se separan y pueden
verse de este lado otra forma de
convencernos de que esto ocurre
es ir un paso más allá y esta parte me
gusta mucho veamos qué ocurre con estos
rayos cuando entran en nuestros ojos
porque eso es lo que realmente importa
eso lo tenemos aquí abajo he dibujado un
par de ojos noten que cuando estos rayos
llegan a nuestros ojos en nuestros ojos
tenemos lentes convergentes en la retina
todos los rayos y todos los colores son
paralelos entre sí y como resultado para
incidir en nuestros ojos quizá recuerden
que todos ellos se van a enfocar en un
solo punto todos los rayos paralelos se
van a enfocar en un solo punto en donde
se enfocan eso depende del ángulo que
formen estos rayos con el eje principal
pero lo importante es que todos se
enfocan en el mismo punto y como
resultado vemos un punto blanco por eso
nos vemos colores porque los rayos
emergentes son paralelos entre sí por
otra parte si consideramos estos rayos
de luz el color rojo llega con un ángulo
particular por lo que todos estos rayos
van a converger en un solo punto
pero el color azul no es paralelo al
color rojo los rayos de color azul
llegan con un ángulo diferente por lo
que se enfocan en un punto diferente
espero que esto nos convenza de que
cuando los rayos y los colores llegan
paralelos entre sí
no vemos colores pero cuando llegan con
ángulos entre ellos si podemos verlos en
resumen cuando la luz pasa a través de
un prisma el rayo emergente no va a ser
paralelo al rayo incidente y es por eso
que cuando tenemos un rayo de luz blanca
los colores se separan pero cuando la
luz blanca incide en un medio de lados
paralelos
el rayo emergente es paralelo al rayo
incidente y es por eso que todos los
colores salen paralelos entre sí por eso
es que no podemos ver los colores esa es
la razón por la que no vemos colores en
la parte de enmedio de la regla pero si
vemos colores en la parte de arriba de
la regla